-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"My dumb bet" stories
from you guys.
This first one
is from @gumgumerson.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting first name.
-Gum.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Grow up, dude.
-"Wake up!"
-This next one's from
@missgreenwalt.
She says...
-Yeah!
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Living the life, man.
-Yeah.
Two beds.
-This one's from @mrcooperclark.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Samuelel.
-Samuel.
-Samuelel, Samuelel.
-Yeah, from the Bible.
-Samuelel.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @logylogues
-Oh, logy logues.
[ Laughter ]
-I wonder if they're friends
with Gum Gumerson.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
There you go.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh!
-That's pretty bad.
That's a pretty bad bet
right there, yeah.
-Now you gotta pay the bets.
-Lost by a hair. Oh.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
That's all right.
Don't get hurt, anybody.
This one's from @CraigLefferts
He said...
[ Laughter ]
"I just thought the Tigers
had a chance, that's all.
Let's go get ice cream!"
-"When you lost."
-This one's from @vestureuk.
He says...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Oh.
Why would you bet that?
-Wow.
Wow.
-What would be worth it?
-That's fantastic.
This last one's
from @rockefeller88.
He says...
There you go, everybody.
-Those are my
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #carfails
from you guys.
Here we go.
First one's from @CTaylor8
She said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I've been there.
This one's from @brendaemily
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm sorry! I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!"
-[Muffled] I'm in the trunk!
-[ Chuckles ]
This one's from @Celizabeth107
She says...
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
-[ Laughing ]
That's a lot of work.
This one's from @beer stat
-Yeah!
-Is that, like, "Beer, stat"
Like that?
Or "Beer stat"?
-No. Maybe like "beer stat."
-Like beer statistics.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I see.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @NewsomScoob
Oh, I know that guy.
-Oh, yeah, you know Newsom
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "He's that good!"
[ High-pitched ]
♪♪ Dream on ♪♪
This one's from @KleoPotato.
-Oh.
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
-That's just perfect, yeah
-Oh!
Down shift.
-This one's from @AllyScheidt.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-That's how it got named.
Sure.
That's a bunch of sh--
That's a bunch of "Scheidt."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Bunch of --
That is a lot of "Scheidt,
but that's from @AllyScheidt
-Yeah, yeah, God bless her
The Screwbaru.
-That's how it got the name.
-That's what she told
her mom, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
This one's from @pottsyMJ.
-Yeah.
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wait!
[ Laughter ]
Wait!
-What?!
I don't know what's going on
-Wait!
-This last one is
from Craig Lefferts.
He says...
There you go. There's our
"Tonight Show Hashtag."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Had to do it" tweets
from you guys.
This first one
is from @fakecoatesy.
He said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Had to -- Had to do it.
-Had to do it.
This is from @ihatetherefs
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Strong opinion.
-Yeah.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He had to do it.
-Yeah, he had to do it.
He had no choice.
[ Laughter ]
-15 minutes picking out a mop.
-Yeah.
-There's lots of different mop
you can get.
-Also, what was he doing
15 minutes watching her?
[ Laughter ]
-He had to do it, right?
-Yeah, he had to do it.
-"I guess not."
Yeah.
-Scotch in his hand.
-Creepy dude, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Nice mop."
-"I wouldn't choose that one."
[ Laughter ]
-"Get outta here, you perv!"
-"Get outta here!
Block you from our store."
-This one is from --
-"And put a shirt on!"
[ Laughter ]
-"I do have a shirt on.
It's just on my legs."
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @littlerose345.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's clever.
That's smart.
-Smart thinking.
-That's clever.
This one's from @ALucilleW
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"I was just joking."
-"Never mind."
"Papa John's!"
-This one's from @Rosarita1.
She says...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Yeah!
Yeah!
Eat it!
♪♪♪♪
Yeah!
-Rosarita!
-Rosarita1!
You know what?
She did win.
Rosarita won.
-She won.
-"What can I have?
Fighting or pleasure?"
-That's fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @WHenhenhen
-Oh.
-I thought I was
just having a stroke there
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-This is from
@WHenhenhenhenhenhenhenhen..
-Ba-gawk, bawk bawk bawk bawk!
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
Interesting.
You got a point.
-Yeah, he's got a point.
[ Laughter ]
-She didn't share
that big old door.
-That's right, yeah.
-And he drowned to death.
-"My jewel!"
-"Oh!
Wait.
What did I do with that?"
-[ As Adam Sandler ] "I droppe
my jewel into the sea!"
-"Mrs. Sandler, please."
[ Laughter ]
-"We ha--
You found it, finally."
[ Laughter ]
"Thank you very much!"
Oh, this one's from @kingedhill.
He says...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ouch.
-Busted, right?
You think you're being clever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That would be funny.
-This last one has a picture
attached to it.
It's from @tutusNtrouble.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Aww!
-Still a cute baby.
[ Applause ]
Cute baby.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags